you
everything in nature is made up of
particles called atoms in the center of
the atom there are protons and neutrons
which consist of quarks this year's
nobel prize in physics has gone to
scientists who have unraveled the
mystery of the most powerful force in
the atom the man of many talents Frank
Phil check is one of three recipients of
the Nobel Prize in Physics his interest
in Quark's began when he was a graduate
student at the simplest level a quark is
a basic building block of matter protons
and neutrons were once called elementary
particles but now we know that they're
actually very complicated objects
the force between quarks is known as the
strong force it has puzzled scientists
for decades this year's second Nobel
laureate in physics is based at the
University of California at Santa
Barbara David gross started working with
Frank will check in the 70s so Frank was
my first graduate student and and he
spoiled me completely because I thought
all registrants were as good as Frank
which I learned was not the case and
some of my later students might have
suffered from that over expectation but
he was very unusual now who is very
crucial to my development that I ran
into this extremely talented and
extremely charismatic young professor at
the time and and we made a very good
team and he really inspired me as he's
inspired a lot of people over the years
to work hard and he brings out the best
in people also had some good ideas
explaining the strong force between
quarks was a formidable task for grouse
and his young protégé if you smash annal
an atom electrons get emitted that's the
basis of all of our electronics it's
easy to remove electrons from an atom
but if you smash protons you just get
more protons or other exotic nucleon
nuclear particles pi ons and cayons and
sigmaz all sorts of names and strange
particles and lots and lots of different
cut but they all are like the proton you
never get a quark along with David
Pulitzer of the California Institute of
Technology will check and gross have
been awarded the nobel prize in physics
for explaining the strong force the
reason the three scientists share the
prize is due to a rare act of generosity
and cooperation
we only found out about his existence
after we had done the essential
calculation but we did decide to publish
our central calculation side by side so
it's not to have any unpleasant kind of
trying to scoop or rivalries while spol
itza worked alone gross and vill check
collaborated setting complex
mathematical problems to calculate how
the strong force worked over various
distances I was trying to think about
you know how you would do this
calculation what it would mean David
wanted the result so he said come on
stop fooling around don't worry about
gage Mary's don't worry about that just
calculate ok so that was me that was
bracing so he's ok so i decided to had
to calculate the theory that emerged was
a theory in which the quarks have
charges we call colors and but those
charges were not observed directly
either because the only object you had
were neutral with respect to these
charges so you couldn't see the
constituents they you couldn't pull him
out of the nucleus you didn't know what
the charges were the force you didn't
know what the forces were and the only
thing you really knew was that whatever
the force was it was very strong
the laureates derived a theory called
quantum chromodynamics to explain the
behavior of quarks it concluded that the
closer the quarks are to each other the
weaker the force between them this
phenomenon was called asymptotic freedom
asymptotic freedom which was them what
was crucial the crucial discovery in
fact told you that the strong force gets
weaker as you go to higher energies or
shorter distances and that's was
unexpected because electromagnetism the
force of electricity and magnetism is a
force that gets stronger at short
distances just the opposite of
asymptotic freedom it was a beautiful
theory but without experiments to prove
it was right some remain skeptical a
colleague of mine and Princeton a few
months after our discovery said to me
David this is great this is really a
nice theory and it might even be right
but it'll never be verified in your
lifetime well it was theoretical but it
was rooted in trying to explain
experimental phenomena and right from
the beginning we saw our task as making
predictions about future experiments
scientists subsequently tested the
laureates theory to see if it stood up
to scrutiny so far they haven't been
able to find any significant flaws this
is very frustrating for the
experimentalist they'd like nothing
better than to prove that accepted
theories or speculative theories are
wrong but so far they haven't succeeded
through their discovery of asymptotic
freedom gross Pulitzer and vil check
have made a monumental contribution to
physics the Nobel Prize is very much a
tribute to their passionate desire to
understand the world life is a great
gift and what I've learned is that for
me at least and I think for many people
one one thing that makes our life
meaningful is figuring out in fact what
is it all about what you know why yeah
why are we here what what what what all
these strange things that are going on
why are they happening and the more you
find out the more you find it's it's
extremely strange and but also in many
ways very
the reason we do what we do is because
we're just awestruck and by the beauty
of what we learned and so those moments
where one discovers something new and
suddenly sees a new structure and a new
insight into how nature works reveal
itself which so often is much more
beautiful than we could have imagined we
are indeed Allah stricken